we are here to learn which means that we  might have to admit that we don't know  everything  we can't just try to justify our own  beliefs but instead we must humble  ourselves and be willing to hear other  people out willing to be wrong willing  to swallow our pride and shift our views  because being a Hills alien means you do  whatever it takes to pursue truth  the best gift that you can give this  institution and certainly the best gift  that you can give any person is your  unreserved  enjoy  you can learn nothing at any moment when  you are not working and just as bad you  cannot help others if you do not prepare  that's why it you have been warned that  this is not easy we hear the faculty  over there we love you why it's so much  fun to watch you everything you do  you're  for the first time including this and  this day I welcome you with the words  that I have said now 17 times is the  last words I say at this Center  get your boots on